wilded means is a complex and oftentimes
the wildering landscape to navigate to
the outsider it's an ever expanding
language of seemingly nonsensical words
and images but to the insider the
symbols of this world are powerful tools
of communication often subject to
controversy transformative meanings and
varying durations of popularity however
since twitch is launched in 2011 one
emote has become the trademark of
sarcasm and continues to thrive atop the
platform's throne that's right we're
finally doing it we're tackling the grey
face no space listen you can't tell me
what the [__] to do we're doing kappa
kappa kappa chino that makes me hyper
what's a kappa the seemingly smug
desaturate advise are seeing right now
is that a former twitch developer Josh -
Sam you back in 2009 he was hired to
work on the chat client for what would
eventually become twitch TV and like
many of his co-workers disea decided to
insert his employee photo as an easter
egg which would appear when a specific
word was typed
he chose the command kappa based on his
love of japanese mythology the japanese
yokai are a collection of various demons
or monsters and the kappa is a kind of
strange water imp complete with beak
shell and a dish on its head that holds
water on an average day the Kappa enjoys
fine activities like eating cucumbers
engaging in some sumo wrestling or
pulling people's souls out of their
butts I'm not joking
[Music]
according to the same you once his face
was initially discovered it was used as
a kind of generic punny replacement for
parts of other words like capo licious
but over time the emote and its command
became synonymous with sarcasm and given
Kappas ceaseless popularity I wanted to
talk to an expert about how this type of
phenomenon emerges and develops yes I
had to seek out a meme overlord one even
greater than I in my quest for mimetic
enlightenment would see me venture to
the University of Toronto and a quiet
office where I'd meet dr. Marcel de nazy
a semi Atisha with over 40 years of
experience in his field
it's a bizarre world in which we live
I'm sorry to put it that way it is
bizarre but I'll tell you as well it's
extremely interesting professor Denis
wrote an entire book about emoji and has
another coming out next year called from
popular culture to mean culture in the
case of emoji many of those symbols had
obvious pre-existing meaning but I asked
professor Dan AZ if there were any cases
he could think of where a near
meaningless set of symbols was simply
handed over to users not in this way but
if you look at all kinds of symbols from
the beginning of time they have and bear
meaning in a context in fact even
magical meaning and emotes are still
signs symbols of a certain type that
accrue meanings through usage and by
through the participation of the users
of these symbols adding to them
developing a kind of suing generous
language that says an awful lot again to
the insider rather than
so it forms a code think about the
eggplant emoji it's just a [__]
eggplant but over time it has developed
a secondary meaning just because it
kinda looks like a so what then was the
early context for kappa well twitch chat
is a medium that viewers use to respond
to streets the say nose face in the
kappa emote appeared perhaps slightly
smug and that was a visual cue for users
the meaning that kappa did eventually
accrue was one of sarcastic intent but
it took time for that to happen
sometimes like we did with our paid by
Steve video it is possible to track this
development but other times it isn't and
Kappa is sold by twitch standards that
it's impossible to know for sure who
first discovered it but Professor Dan AC
points something else out as well many
people using the emote may not even
fully understand what they're doing as
you see tribal symbols and rituals
evolve and you're an outsider you look
at them as a fact is going on if you're
an insider they bear meaning by the vert
by virtue of the fact that they form a
cohesive pastiche most of those people
have no idea come quickly what thing
they've inherited this from the
connotations that they have had over
time it's a kind of distributed meaning
that we acquire not intentionally but by
osmosis I don't know what better work
the idea that people don't know the
concrete meaning of a symbol is the
reason we can do this series at all you
guys know something intuitively about
the emos that you use but you click on
our videos to confirm your understanding
and seeker greater context over the
course of history
mankind has attempted to create
universal symbols for signifying the
presence of irony or sarcasm via text
and those efforts have largely failed
but could kappa finally solve this
problem while its uses currently limited
to twitch TV users
as the platform streaming and mean
culture continues to grow in popularity
so to dis Kappas global presence it
transcends the boundaries of written
language and has developed something of
a cult following
[Music]
Kappas rampant popularity has spawned a
number of variations and even fanatics
who revel in its use it's not I'm not
gonna ask you seeing me happy birthday
but I asked professor de neige see how
symbolic meaning is decided between
groups and what factors come into play
when determining it from tribal cultures
till now it's the quest for me I don't
know why I if I had the answer I
wouldn't be here talking into a YouTube
channel boom roasted sorry I love
YouTube channels but what we can confirm
is that Kappa is the biggest emote on
twitch and that's unlikely to change
anytime soon
and while the see Nia wasn't even really
with twitch during the emotes rise to
popularity he has kept track of it on
his personal website now living in Japan
he seems amused by it suggesting that
his face could possibly be the most
digitally reproduced ever for something
that was added as a joke it seems truly
fitting that Kappa has come to symbolize
just that great job man I'm really happy
with how this one turned out what can I
say I'm a one-man show
[Music]
you know I love grumpy cat you know I
don't know why I had a cat
in fact I danced for the first time your
question is making me think and make
associations it makes me laugh at the
same time it makes me think and so on
and that therefore leads me to say right
now that mean culture is an associated
culture it is not just concocted on the
spot which I thought it was because it
connected me to my previous experience
which obviously are shared by many
others so in a way that is now that I
think about it it's probably my favorite